[Music]
hi i'm drew barrymore and i want to
welcome you to episode 1
of the making of we really want to bring
you behind the scenes
of what this year-long journey has been
like for us creating this show
it's been exciting it's been scary
it's been challenging
but really at the end of the day is been
an opportunity
that we want to realize in ways that
exceed
expectations so
i think the best way to do that is to
peel back the curtain
and bring you in because what happens
behind the scenes i think is sometimes
even more important than what you see
out in front
and my whole life has led to this
and before 2020 we had been proceeding
to make
a daytime talk show i don't think we
were gonna fall
totally prey to pitfalls and trappings
and tropes
and cliches but i feel like the show we
were making then
probably does fall in that category and
because
it is our responsibility to meet this
moment
it was the how that was challenging
but it's like the control room's so fun
because you can control fake well you
know i like all control oh
i feel like halogen or a can light on
top of the head thank you mitchell
i also realized that with a certain
amount of money
and a certain amount of time you go on
this sort of
roller coaster ride to accomplish
something and you're working with new
people and you're all getting to know
each other and
everybody's working you know at a
thousand miles an hour and trying to hit
every cylinder and you're high-fiving
and you're
staying late and you're communicating a
lot i wanted to have a lot of group
meetings so that everyone was on the
same page about what the tone was
as soon as it was over i needed to know
what would get us over a finish line
to make the show we were really gonna
make and then it'll either be
four and five or four and five okay
thank you jerry
jerry
yes the sales tape is an audition it's
been a very unique life
and yet 44 years into it
i feel more alive and more appropriate
for this job than ever
i started working when i was 11 months
old
and i pretty much raised myself
sometimes for worse
sometimes for better my journey in life
hasn't been perfect
but the liberation of that is not having
to pretend to be perfect
i know sorry i know what it's like to be
on the other side so i know exactly what
to do you're also killing yourself at a
thousand miles an hour
um with a group of people not knowing if
it's gonna work
and i've been auditioning my whole life
um i
i associate rejection with a filet o
fish
because every time i didn't get an
audition my mom would take me
for a filleto fish
there's you'd think that would be
demoralizing but it's kind of like
the underdog and you get even more
voracious about
going you know what we have to make this
work
and even if we're just trying to figure
this out and get it
done and we know we'll do things
different in the future
we have got to make this work or there
is no future
i have flown all over the country i've
met with every single sales team
i've met with most of the station groups
so everyone was calling me
congratulations and i would have to say
it's not a done deal which just was so
awkward but
it wasn't we'd all flown down to miami
and armando nunes and steve ocasio
who had become wonderful
supporters and allies and
champions of this and we had had so many
dinners and so many meetings
about is this going to happen
they ordered a gorgeous bottle of wine
and
that i couldn't drink because once they
said that it was official i basically
was running back and forth
from the bathroom having one of the
biggest panic attacks i've ever had in
my life
i can't really explain it i was joking
with rich cervini
i was like i've just been the lucky
recipient of um
being a part of a talk show and i can't
talk rich like they're gonna fire me the
second they hired me
it's official drew barrymore will host
her own daytime talk show
it's slated to launch in the fall of
next year who's covering the daytime
television
okay girl we're a full service operation
i have so much work every single day to
figure out and reinvent
and re-spark that fire and just
get down to what is worth being on the
air
what are people gonna respond to and yet
you cannot think anyone's watching
basically said we as cbs you will be
working here
this will be your sound stage
and you will get the privilege of being
in these offices right across the street
and when i walked in the office i just
started to cry because i
totally had my working girl fantasy
and i just there is something about a
desk
that seems like this
grounding block of concrete that
doesn't weigh me down it anchors me
because my whole life in work has been
so
transient and so liberating and so
like much of what made me like
sort of a fluid person that i am
i think i was always looking for that
anchor
and somehow the metaphor of a desk
really felt like
this anchor that i would never ever have
i am excited
to not play a character
to just get to be me um
i'm excited to
take all the things i've learned along
the way
and apply it to this new job where i do
get to be myself
and i know
that i continue to be so lucky and
fortunate
and i'm just i'm never gonna take this
room for granted
i mean cue the carly simon music
this is my office
i this was on the window
so these will be all the producer
offices this room
is really special to me because this
will be
the executive producers office who's
really our showrunner
jason kind of how i see this process is
i hosted saturday night live for the
first time in 1982
in new york and i
remember being in the offices in
monday morning you go in and you sit in
the office it's usually lauren it's
lauren michael's office and
all the casts and the writers and
everybody sits on the floor and
lauren sits at his desk and it's a small
office
it's not bigger than this it might even
be smaller than this
and everybody piles in and you all feel
like puppies together
so when i saw this room it just made me
think of lauren michaels and
saturday night live really is a training
ground for me and
it's so community and it's so personal
and like i said you just feel like a
pile of puppies so
this will be our lauren michael's office
the world health organization says the
risk of the virus expanding worldwide is
now classified as
very high bright lights of hollywood are
dark and the impact is epic
here's cbs's but then that all changed
and all of a sudden
i was positive that this was not going
to happen again
in the second week of march and i
understood that
i mean anyone who can see what was
happening in the world and was going to
be like oh this show isn't going it's
like oh my god
shut up and get some perspective are you
kidding me we're in a pandemic
so i felt weird even feeling sad or bad
or trying to mourn something that i
didn't believe was really going to
happen
again as soon as it said like this is
official
we got knocked off our feet again as
everyone did
so then you're kind of working again
like in that sales tape mode like i
think i might be putting so much into
something that may never really happen
um but we did and we kept going
[Music]
you